pour le week-end faire une randonnée à
pied au-dessus de Chamonix
le capitaine annonce le décès au
procureur de la République c'est un
couloir avec des barres rocheuses
qui par le couloir en fait ce qu'il y a
dû se passer c'est
que qui a chuté donc là c'est plus de
200 m voilà et son papa donc est
descendu et lui on estime sa chute à 200
m donc le fils est plus de 200 m donc
c'est un grand couloir de neige avec des
barres rocheuses qui qui c'est un truc
couple
c'est la chute donc j'ai le médecin à
côté de moi qui me dit qu'ils sont très
certainement décédés
[Musique]
à l'arrêt de la chute ou juste après
quoi
dès le départ en doutait que c'était un
peu ça quoi voilà le fait qu'on puisse
pas recontacter le papa sur une zone
dans la vallée de Chamonix ou
normalement il y a pas de zone d'ombre
de portable voilà c'était assez critique
mort par méconnaissance de la montagne
ça les gendarmes devront l'expliquer aux
familles
expliquer ça n'est pas toujours le cas
Patrice tient à me montrer trois
classeurs qu'il conservent précieusement
le registre des disparus du Mont-Blanc
au fil des années 150 personnes sont
portées disparues dans les glaces
par exemple c'est quoi un mexicain
qui serait disparu dans le massif du
Mont-Blanc secteur Mont-Blanc vallée de
Chamonix
avalanche chute en crevasse alpinistes
égaré il arrive que la montagne ne
rentre jamais ce qu'elle a pris
[Musique]
il y a des histoires incroyables
là-dedans il y avait je sais pas si
c'est une femme ou un fils ou je peux
regarder
ouais c'est les parents sont les parents
monsieur nous avons appris que plusieurs
cordes alpinis disparus depuis plusieurs
années avaient été retrouvées dans le
massif du Mont-Blanc notre fils lui
aussi disparu en tentant en solitaire
hivernal l'arête de Peter c'était début
janvier 84 les experts en montagne
pensent qu'il était arrivé très près du
but cela nous permet de penser qu'il
repose peut-être dans le glacier si par
hasard la montagne un jour rendait son
corps vous serait-il possible d'en
prendre une photographie avant
l'altération qui est très rapide
lorsqu'il est sorti de son enveloppe de
glace nous espérons que vous comprendrez
notre requête
waouh
89 5 ans après ils écrivent ça pour les
familles c'est dur
la plupart de ces documents concernent
des disparitions d'alpinistes et de
skieur mais pas seulement
malheureusement le point de départ des
premiers disparus c'était en 1950 avec
la normale
vous n'avez 43 passagers
ah oui ça c'est un avion
le mâle princesse un avion indien qui
s'est écrasé sur les contreforts du
Mont-Blanc un accident sans aucun
survivant qui n'a toujours pas fini de
révéler ses secrets et donc on retrouve
des débris de ces avions de temps en
temps
il y a des administes qui nous ont
ramené une sacoche diplomatique
qu'on a restitué à son propriétaire et
qui était dans un de ses avions
avec des documents en l'état quoi
pratiquement on n'a pas ouvert puisque
c'est diplomatique
mais vous vous êtes gendarmes
et les gendarmes on le sens du devoir
c'est un peu leur deuxième nature
nouvelle alerte il est 17h30 dans une
heure et demie il fera nuit dans la
vallée le ciel est encore bleu mais là
haut le mauvais temps menace et choucas
repas
est-ce qu'il y aura des tresses vient
d'appeler il a fait une lourde chute il
se plaint d'une forte douleur à la
hanche
l'hélicoptère nous dépose à 3700 mètres
d'altitude il fait très froid à cause du
vent il y a beaucoup de brouillard
la progression est difficile
le skieur d'une trentaine d'années est
encore groggy par sa chute
mais ça n'est pas l'état de santé du
skieur qui inquiète le plus Patrice
j'espère qu'on va pas se faire enfermer
se faire enfermer traduction être pris
dans le brouillard et ne plus être
visible par l'hélicoptère ce que je
te propose
est-ce que ça te va
[Musique]
c'est pareil ouais
le skieur ce serait cassé le bassin une
fracture très douloureuse
faire un peu les dents on va aller au
chaud je te mets ce qu'il faut comme
médicament contre la douleur on fait un
petit peu plus le point mais au chaud
après on va le suivre
la température chute brutalement il fait
moins 22 degrés par ce froid tout
liquide gel immédiatement impossible de
faire une piqûre de morphine pour
soulager le blessé
l'hélicoptère est attendu avec
impatience
mais plus l'hélicoptère approche plus le
brouillard s'épaisser
le pilote ne nous voit plus il va
falloir changer de stratégie aller
chercher plus haut une percée dans les
nuages
après de 4000 mètres d'altitude la
moindre manœuvre devient une épreuve
le blessé est transit froid et de
douleur
l'équipe reçoit un message radio
l'hélicoptère fait une nouvelle
tentative d'approche
voilà
je force pas
ok écoute
impossible d'atterrir ou de treuillet
les pisteurs doivent finalement
descendre le blessé à ce qui
les sauveteurs rentrent à pied
l'hélico les récupérera un peu plus bas
une heure plus tard juste avant la nuit
le PGHM vit encore dans le souvenir de
Sébastien mort en montagne il y a 15
jours à peine
entre gendarmes on vit avec le danger
mais on en parle pas et de la mort
encore moins
je décide d'aller rencontrer celle qui
les connaissent le mieux leur femme
bonjour
ça va
c'est Stéphanie la femme de Jeff qui me
reçoit avec deux de ses copines elles
aussi femmes de gendarmes
[Musique]
première surprise si elles sont
amoureuses de leur mari elle n'aime pas
forcément la montagne
parce que la passion absolue de la
montagne vous la partagez avec eux ou
pas
aucune d'entre nous
on est vraiment là par amour
moi j'aime pas le froid j'aime pas la
montagne
[Musique]
question du
danger et des risques que prennent vos
maris
ouais c'est une question qui fâche en ce
moment un petit peu
depuis la mort
[Musique]
arriver à n'importe qui mais voilà le
fait que ce soit un proche le fait que
ce soit un gars qui était
qui avait le secourisme dans la peau on
n'accepte pas on n'accepte pas que ce
soit lui qui soit passé
ça vient dire quoi que c'est possible
quoi
même on a envie pas tous les jours avec
mais
on vit notre vie on fait on fait nos
journées comme comme des femmes
ordinaires quoi
mais c'est sûr que voilà le vu le métier
qui font
pas forcément
[Musique]
de temps de tolérance avec ce avec nos
hommes parce que
c'était pas tolérant le groupe il peut
pas tenir c'est sûr c'est sûr qu'il y a
l'amour de la famille à l'amour des
enfants mais on fait avec quoi moi j'ai
toujours dit à Jean-François c'est elle
le sait la montagne c'est sa maîtresse
de toute façon c'est le contrat de base
et le départ oui
vous avez pris des montagnards
[Musique]
retour au PGHM et direction le chenil
j'ai rendez-vous avec Max l'un des trois
maîtres chiens il y a combien de chiens
c'est tous les chiens d'avalence voilà
pister l'été pour rechercher les
personnes égarées donc le matin c'est un
moment important parce que c'est le
moment où on va voir si le chien en
forme ou pas un chien a battu on le voit
de suite et là ça a l'air d'aller
très bien il a l'air très abattu
bonjour me voilà présenté à burn un
malinois en pleine force de l'âge
6 ans 6 ans passés au cœur de sa
carrière
il a encore tout le physique et là
aujourd'hui ça sera un travail de
remotivation du chien parce que il est
déjà allé sur une avalanche sous
laquelle il n'a rien trouvé parce qu'il
y avait personne c'était une
vérification donc là c'est un peu un
exercice facile pour le remotiver et lui
redonner confiance
[Musique]
et pour remotiver burn il nous faut
aller à 1800 mètres d'altitude
ces derniers jours la neige est tombée
en masse je progresse péniblement
pour cet exercice Max a besoin de trois
éléments essentiels un trou une victime
ça sera moins et un drôle d'objet voilà
donc la personne qui a un cheveu qui
joue le rôle de victime elle a toujours
le jouet du chien avec elle du moins en
face d'entraînement parce que le chien
en fait il associe l'odeur de la
personne ensevelie à son jouet ce qu'il
veut c'est chercher son jouet
est avec d'accord et comme c'est un
fanatique du jouet pour tous les chiens
d'avalanche c'est ça qui le motive donc
je mets le jouet devant quoi dès que le
chien va percer il faudra lui donner son
jouet et résister de façon à ce qu'ils
doivent encore plus lutter pour le
récupérer
au revoir
bon ben c'est à moi de jouer maintenant
[Musique]
bon je suis pas claustrophobe mais quand
même
et je rentre pas
je suis là je suis là je me demande
comment ça va être quand ils vont fermer
parce que quand même enfin bon
je commet entouré de gendarme donc
on est pas mal
quand on a l'air pour respirer tu dois
pas être le cas d'un
gars qui est pris dans une avalanche
[Musique]
dans une avalanche si l'on ne meurt pas
sur le cou on peut tenir de 15 à 45
minutes tout dépend de la taille de la
poche d'air
les morceaux de moi
[Musique]
écoute c'est pas des agréable c'est la
convoit que cette idée de faire un trou
quand on est pris dans une tempête dans
la neige il fait chaud dedans plus on
est près de la Terre et moi il fait
froid plus on se rapproche du zéro degré
mais fin de la récré l'hélicoptère
repart pour une mission beaucoup moins
ludique
l'évacuation d'un skieur d'une trentaine
d'années l'homme a fait une chute de 10
mètres dans une crevasse il ne l'a pas
vu
il est mort sur le coup
[Musique]
il rejoint la liste des 75 corps sans
vie que les hommes du PGHM redescendent
chaque année
c'est quoi ce papier c'est certificat de
décès
sentiment d'impuissance
c'est par rapport à quelqu'un qui
est malade ou pas finalement s'attendre
quand même une issue
là c'est quelqu'un qui allait
parfaitement bien et un quart d'heure
après 3 minutes après les morts
les hommes des pompes funèbres sont là
pour emmener le corps
[Musique]
j'en ai vu des morts dans ma vie mais
celui-là c'est vraiment étrange
parce que parce que ça colle pas avec le
décor parce que ça colle pas avec le
grand soleil qui avait aujourd'hui parce
que l'endroit était justement magnifique
parce que c'est une bêtise parce que non
c'est vraiment étrange vraiment étrange
ce type est mort
extrêmement bêtement quoi
bon même si on est blindé comme on
on est un soir comme ça
pour lui ça pourrait être un copain
quelqu'un de la famille
on rentre avec à la maison ou pas
un petit peu un petit peu après faut
s'en détacher si on en fait un cas de
consciences systématique je pense que on
arrête on arrête après voilà c'est faut
souvenir des vivants qu'on a ramené
ouais et puis heureusement c'est la
grande majorité voilà
je préfère aller chercher quelqu'un qui
s'est fait peur ou qui avait pas le
niveau de passer un endroit et puis il
revient avec nous ici il est content et
puis ça restera gravé dans sa mémoire
plutôt que d'aller chercher un gars qui
s'éclatait à faire du ski passer une
super journée et puis qu'on ramène là
pour les morts
sinon c'est les pompes funèbres
générales sinon ils vont se faire faire
un hélico et puis
ça serait triste quand même
le soleil finit par se lever et un
rescapé de la veille vient remercier ses
sauveurs un petit billet en poche qui
viendra nourrir une caisse de secours
donc au final vous avez un énorme atome
sur le côté je mets de la glace
ils sont venus me chercher le jour blanc
c'était pas forcément très facile pour
vous et puis cette amitié risquée c'est
normal qu'on participe
le jour blanc c'est le jour où nous nous
sommes retrouvés enfermés dans le
brouillard j'aurais tapé la tête
pareil j'étais mort
ça arrive de temps en temps ce genre de
ça vous fait quoi
une personne que tu as secouru parce
qu'en fait on a on connaît rarement les
suites une fois qu'on pose les gens à
l'hôpital mais on sait jamais il y a
toujours des diagnostics mais qui sont
pas forcément confirmés donc là on est
content de voir un monsieur qui est une
suspicion de traumatisme assez grave et
qui au final se retrouve juste avec un
seul hématome donc on est content de le
voir marcher 24 heures après
en bonne santé il va pouvoir continuer à
faire du ski donc non c'est bien pour
tout le monde
dans les Alpes comme dans les Pyrénées
ils sont plus de 300 à risquer leur vie
chaque jour pour nous secourir hiver
comme été
aux côtés des gendarmes de Chamonix j'ai
croisé beaucoup de ski épuisés égarés
j'ai vu des luxations des entorses le
plus souvent sans gravité
mais j'ai compris que sans
l'intervention de ces sauveteurs même
les petites blessures peuvent très vite
tourner à la tragédie car on ne
plaisante pas avec la montagne
un mois après mon départ un autre
gendarme de Chamonix est mort en
exercice il avait 35 ans et une petite
fille de 5 ans
[Musique]
il est temps pour moi de repartir à la
découverte de nouveaux horizons où ma
tante d'autres hommes et d'autres femmes
au métier exceptionnel